[موسيقى]
جميع مناشداته لم تلقى منها اذنا صغيرا
كان يختنق داخل تلك الحقيبه الصغيره
ويتوسل اليها لاخراجه لكنها بقيت تضحك
وتتشفى به الى ان لفظ انفاسه الاخيره
الاسم ساره بول التهمه القتل
المكان فلوريدا الولايات المتحده
في الرابع والعشرين من فبراير عام 2020
اتصالا من امراه تدعى ساره بول وتبلغ من
العمر 42 عاما للتبليغ عن وفاه صديقها
داخل حقيبه سفره
عند وصول الشرطه وخلال التحقيقات زعمت
ساره انها وصديقها المدعوه توريس جونيور
كان تحت تاثير الكحول في الليله السابقه
واتفقا على ان يلعب لعبه الغميضه وان
صديقها اقترح ان يضع نفسه داخل حقيبه
السفر ثم صعدت هيا للنوم في الطابق العلوي
بعدما اقفلتها عليه لتستيقظ في صباح اليوم
التالي وتجده مفارقا للحياه داخل الحقيبه
للوهله الاولى بدلا للمحققين ان الوفاه
كانت حادثا لكن الصدمه جاءت عندما فتشوا
في هاتف ساره المحمول الشرطه وجدت مقطع
فيديو سجلته ساره بنفسها في تلك الليله
ظهرت فيه حقيبه زرقاء قلب وجهها للاسفل
وكانت تسمع منها صرخات توريس واستغاثته
لساره لتخرجه من الحقيبه لانه لم يعد
قادرا على التنفس ورغم كل تلك التوسلات
كانت ساره تضحك وتتشفى بحالاته داخل
الحقيبه مؤكده ان هذا جزاء من يخونها
تسع ساعات كامله بقي فيها توريس محتاجه
داخل الحقيبه ساره لا تزال تسر على انها
لم تقصد قتله وانها استسلمت للنوم تحت
تاثير الكحول فيما يناقض تسجيل الفيديو
هذه الروايه والان تقبع ساره في السجن
بانتظار محاكمتها في شهر يوليو من عام
[موسيقى]